[Musique]
j'ai tout est chez moi à metz puisque
pour une opportunité comme celle ci il
faut photo quitter il faut partir parce
que cette question sarah celi et la
nouvelle gérante des sycomores l'atelier
de restauration de meubles anciens est
installé depuis une douzaine d'années
rue du maréchal gallieni à versailles
elle-même restauratrice de mobilier
ancien et d'objets d'art elle a envoyé
sa candidature pour poursuivre
l'activité c'est le seul qui m'a répondu
j'avais envoyé six ou sept courriers en
pleine pandémie donc c'est un peu
compliqué mais en fait c'est le seul qui
m'a répondu et il m'a expliqué que lui
me proposerait pas un poste d'employé
mais il proposerait son poste à lui donc
gérant quant à bouaye sont ces débats
puisqu'il va dire qui en veut qui est
l'âme ya dix jours et qui semble être à
ils ont eu lieu dans mon sens ancien
expert à l'insead aujourd'hui son
atelier content de pouvoir faire
perdurer son activité il lui transmet
son savoir faire depuis un an tales qui
pourra les rendez-vous qui je vais
encore avec elle voir les clients pour
que lé s'habitue à voir l'importance du
travail pour telle ou telle chose
qu'elle puisse ensuite faire les
estimations de vix et on s'entend très
bien de ce côté là en tant
qu'entrepreneur sahara était accompagné
dans son projet par la chambre des
métiers et de l'artisanat de versailles
j'ai pas eue j'ai pas eu un parcours
semé d'embûches mais par contre il faut
en vouloir s'il faut avoir faut être
dynamique faut avoir d'énergie parce que
donc c'est un mois ça a pris quasiment
ouvert un an sur place on trouve de tout
des objets d'exception de style ou
d'époque comme ce baromètre du xviiie
siècle en bois doré ce cartel du xviie
siècle ou encore cette commode régence
d'époque
[Musique]
un métier
passionnant parce qu'en fait on s'ennuie
jamais on ne fait jamais la même chose
on travaille jamais sur les mêmes
pièce donc c'est passionnant et à chaque
fois on est obligé de trouver des
solutions différentes des méthodes de
travail différentes pour chaque problème
les meubles à restaurer viennent de
particuliers ou d'institutions comme le
château de versailles
[Musique]